CERTAINLY THAT RECORD FOLLOWING
A LOSS IS SOMETHING TO TAKE A
GREAT DEAL AWAY WE AND THAT'S C.
NOW BOZAK GOES BACK TO THE GOAL.
CALGLG SNAPPED OFF THE
SHAFT OF THE STICK.
THAT'S A BIG BREAK FOR THE
BLUES, JOHN.IN BOSTON, AND THATD
BACK IN.OU SEE RIGHT
THROUGH THE MIDDLE AND TAKES THE
OUTLET BUCHNEVICH.
HE CAME BACK.
MADE A GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAY.
HAD BEEN SHUT OUT, HE'S SNAPPED
AN 18-GOAL DROUGHT LAST NINI
FACE-OFF, SHOT BY PARAYAY
ON HOME ICE THIS
HERE IS THE GAUDREAU PLAY.
TKACHUK HAS THIS ROLL OFF THEIDS
NOT THE CASE WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT
SITUATION.
YOU HAVE TO COME BACK AND
.LEMANH.
BOY, THE BLUES GAVE HIM ALL
KINDS OF ROOM.
HE DID A THAT'S THE RECIPE FOR -
THAT'S NOT THE RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS RIGHT T BY -- BACKGROUNY
HUSSO AS HE READ IT WELL A A KYE
FIRST SHOT.
NOW HANIFIN WITH IT.
THAT SHOHOP HIGH.
FINDS PERRON, TIPPED ALONG FOR
SAADHAT
MARKSTROM COULD SEE THIS HERE
FROM THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
YOU SEE TOREYEY
BLADE AND INTO THE NET.
>> WHAT A SHOT BY SAAD AND THE
BLUES TAKE A 3-1
CALGARY COMES BACK.
GOES TO THE COVERAGE IN THE NET.
NOBODY FINDS HIM.
HE SNAPS IT HOME.
FRONT OF THE NET WITH THE
BUCHNEVICH GOES DOWN, STAYS WITH
IT, THOUGHUSLY
DOESN'T LIKE THAT GOAL.
>> CALGARY PENALTY #17,CALLY ILL
CHILDREN.
>> BACKLUND ALREADY HAS ONE IN
THIS GAME.
LOOKED LIKE IT ROLLED OFF THE
BACK SIDE OF HIS BLADE.
>> WITH THE
AND A SHOT ON GOAL BY TKACHUK.
ANOTHER SHOT AND A SAVE BY HUSSO
NOW THE FLAMES ON THE OUTSIDE.
HERE IS MONAHAN.
OF THEIR LAST SIX
GAMES.
5 FOR 20. UP HIGH.
A GLOVED SAVE BY HUSSO.
AND WE GET A
TARASENKO WHIPS IT AROUND BACK.
SCHENN LET'S IT G GIRE
LEAGUE.
WATCH #6 ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN.
HE BEATS RITCHIE TO THAT GOOD PR
THAT IN WHEN SAAD HAS SPEED.
PUT IT INA HURDLER
IN HIGH SCHOOL IN THE TORONTO
AREA.
KRUG TRYING TO DO IT HIMSELF
HERE.
NOW BACK FOR PERRON